if a recipe calls for a hot pan put on  early so it gets smoking hot and always  remember to preheat your oven at least  20 minutes before cooking  a clean cook is an efficient cook my tip  for a tidy cooking area is to always  have a waste bowl next to you it saves  you going back and forth to the bin  never add salt to eggs before cooking  them because it ruins the texture and  dulls the color instead save your  seasoning to the very end  the key to cooking meat is to make sure  it's at room temperature before you  begin cook straight from the fridge the  muscle fibers will be tight which  results in tough meat and always let it  rest afterwards so relax is becoming  tender and juicy